[Music]
hello everyone
uh in the previous lecture i had
mentioned that i would be taking up an
example so here it is we are considering
a very thin beam or column
or bar rod whatever you want to call it
uh
in this fashion and it may look that
there is something very special going on
at the top but
uh i mean it's really nothing it's just
a hinged end uh
except that it is so arranged that
this hinged end is uh
is free to slide along like this okay in
the vertical direction
uh on the other hand this hinged end
so that support itself is uh
is attached to a certain wall or ground
okay as you want to understand it anyway
so
what is going to happen is that uh when
we
apply a vertically downward load
a force like this then it is of course
going to
compress and because we have these kinds
of
rollers here it can actually compress
okay
now we know from our physical
understanding or intuition or maybe from
our undergraduate knowledge
that uh beyond a certain
value of this force let's say this is p
uh it is going to buckle this this
slender rod
is going to buckle okay but we want to
address this buckling in a systematic
fashion
based on the theory that we have been
developing so let us take a look back
at the equations that we arrived at in
the previous video
so these are the set of equations uh
what i'll do is i just copy paste
this the set of equations and see
how we may specialize this general set
of equations
uh to the specific case is at hand
all right so i have my set of equations
here
okay so the objective here is clear that
we want to find out
the value of the critical force p okay
which will induce
buckling and in the process we want to
get some insights
into the deflection because you see the
governing equation that we have here
that certainly involves the the variable
p
but it is an equation it is a
differential
equation in terms of the deflection w so
let us see
what insights we can obtain about the w
also okay so our immediate job now
is to uh is to
uh understand the specific boundary
conditions
which will be applicable given this kind
of a physical setup
okay so what we'll do is first of all
we'll set up our coordinate axis
so let's say we have our
x vertically upward here and
z like this okay up
which means that our y will be pointing
out of the plane of the
string but i'm not going to draw that
here uh just to
avoid any clutter so you understand that
the deflection w
that is taking place along the z
direction okay and
all the axial compression that is going
to take place
along this x direction or specifically
along the negative x direction
but uh of course you know that in the
way that we have found out our or
reduced our set of equations that a
stretching variable
us has disappeared okay so uh
i i suggest that if if these terms the
stretching variable and such other
things
are not very familiar to you you please
take a look at the previous video
all right now
as i was saying our first job at hand is
to specialize
our boundary conditions given this
physical setup
so we have these boundary conditions at
x
equal to zero and at x equal to l we
have these things so
uh you first of all note that at x equal
to zero
okay at x equal to zero what is
specified
okay if at all anything at x equal to 0
we know for a fact
that this w is very much specified
because uh it is constrained against
moving in the z direction so w
is equal to zero okay
similarly at x equal to l okay
at the other end the w is again zero
please do not confuse uh with the fact
that
u s is not specified okay
that is true that us is not specified
the stretching variable is not specified
because this end
can actually move down so we don't know
how much it will move down
but w is in the z direction so w is not
is is very much specified
okay it is constrained it is moving in
this z direction at x equal to l
so now one thing we are sure is that
this is true
w is specified okay
so this double tick mark uh you can kind
of
understand it that one tick mark for x
equal to zero
and the other tick mark for x equal to l
what about
the other set of boundary conditions
you see again both these ends are hinged
ends
hinge dense means there is no resistance
against the rotation of this end
there is no resistance against the
rotation
at this end and since there is no
resistance against the rotation
we do not know anything uh
a priory about the slope that
this beam or the rod can take okay
since since that rotation is is not
resisted
uh we do not know a priority what the
slope will be
okay so suppose instead instead of this
uh
hinged end this was a clamped end
okay so a clamped end would uh
i mean the the implication of a clam
clandent is that
the rotation is completely prevented
which means that the slope
is fixed okay so that is not the case
here
so this dwdx which represents the slope
that is certainly not specified and that
is true
at x equal to zero as well as at x equal
to l
so because this is not specified it is
the other condition
the either or okay so it is always this
uh this sort of a toss-up between the
either and or if one of them is
not specified the other must be true so
here we have e i d square w d x
square is equal to 0 and again we will
put
two tick marks here to represent the
fact that this is true at
x equal to 0 and at x equal to l so
in totality what we have is this
for our governing differential equation
we have this equation
there is no doubt about it you have only
one equation
and please note that this is a fourth
order ordinary differential equation
okay and because it is a fourth order
ordinary differential equation we will
need four conditions to solve it
and those four conditions will be given
by the two conditions at x equal to zero
this and this and the two conditions at
x equal to l
this and this okay so that's all that we
have to do
so this physical problem or this
mechanical problem that we have in our
hand
that has now been reduced to just
solving this differential equation
subject to this boundary conditions
okay and the moment we can do that we
are very happy because we have all been
trained in
first engineering mathematics so we can
we can
proceed let us do that okay
and see what happens all right so first
of all we have to deal with this
equation
and to solve this equation uh i mean you
can have different methods
but what we are going to do is uh
so first of all what i'll do is i'll
just uh
rewrite this equation in a slightly
different form
okay let me write this
in this form i will divide two out
by this e i so that
i end up with
this
furthermore you note that for our
problem
this q is equal to zero i do not have
the presence of any lateral load
okay you understand that this uh this
was copy pasted from the general theory
just like the boundary conditions were
copy pasted so
uh for the specific case at hand q is
equal to zero
so i don't have to worry about the right
hand side that is just zero
okay now what we do is usually this p
by e i uh you note that this p is a
is a positive thing this is positive i
is positive
so this entire thing is positive so what
we'll do is
we will just write this particular
combination as
a square
the k square denotes that this
particular combination
is positive no matter what the value of
k may be okay
uh if you if you wanted you could have
written this simply as k
and just said that k is has to be
positive uh but
the way that we are going to end up with
the solution it it just
it's just the answer shows up in a nicer
fashion
if we if we start out with this k square
and you will see why
okay now we have to solve this
so to solve this
what we do is we assume a solution form
we assume a solution form
which is w is equal to e to the power mx
the motivation for taking this e to the
power mx form
uh where m is something unknown yet we
have to solve for it
is that you see that uh
i mean this this uh this kinds of
derivatives
okay so if you if you operate uh this
derivatives on this thing
it will keep on giving up multiples of
m if you differentiate once you'll get m
uh m square m cube m four
all those things but the heart and soul
of this
the the way that it depends on x that
remains unchanged
okay and that has certain benefits in
the way that the solution can be
attacked okay uh so let us not get
too much into the mathematical theory
behind that
uh and let us try to try to solve this
thing
okay so let me go to the next page
if i substitute this w is equal to e to
the power mx form here
what am i going to get
so this thing
m4 m to the power 4
plus k square n square is equal to 0
you note what has happened is that i'm
also getting this e to the power m
x here and e to the power mx here that i
have just
canceled out okay now
this can be written like this and now
you see
that uh it's quite easy to write down
the solution
uh what we will obtain is that this m s
it is
this n square equal to 0 or m square
plus k square equal to 0
those two conditions will give us the 0
values for this
so what we are going to end up with is
this
0 0 we make it a point to write this 0
twice
to actually explicitly show that
0 is indeed a repeated root and that
will have some consequence in the way
that the
solution shapes up for the roots from
this m square plus k square equal to 0
part
what we are going to have is a
plus minus i e
okay where you note this i is the
familiar square root
of minus one so i hope
nobody will have any problem with this
so given that
uh we have ended up with this m uh how
can we write the
w okay so we have four roots here
so uh but
let's write
so let's use different coefficients for
each of these
choices of m
okay so first of all for this repeated
root
0 0 i have to write this as c x
plus d okay so if you're not sure what
what has gone on there you need to
revise your first
engineering mathematics so suppose
suppose this were
not m square this were just m okay and
then it was m times n square plus k
square say one so
what you would have obtained is m equal
to zero in that case
all that you have to do is to just think
that this is like
some c into e to the power 0 x
and that is just c okay so we're not
having anything like this
but it is also wrong to think that this
would be because it is a
0 and 0 it will be like c e to the power
0 x
plus d e to the power 0 x that would be
wrong okay
so to know more about the theory you
really need to uh
revise the first range in mathematics
okay
uh regarding the other part this plus
minus ik you note that i have written
this as
a dash and b dash uh just to
just to prepare myself for the fact that
i would like to
write rewrite this thing not in terms of
this exponentials
rather in terms of cos and sign okay so
what i'm going to do is this e to the
power i k that i'm going to write as
uh cos k plus i sin k and this has cos k
minus i sin k and then i am going to to
combine those cos
terms and the sign terms and ultimately
what i am going to obtain
is something like this
now please note that i have missed the x
here okay that should be written
so this is k cos x plus k x
plus b sine
kx plus cx
plus d so that's my solution for our
w
all right so now all that i have to do
is to utilize
my boundary conditions one by one so let
me just take a quick look at what the
boundary conditions are
at x equal to zero and at x equal to l i
have
uh the w is specified and indeed this w
is specified is actually
that uh this w is actually zero
okay so this is only for the special
case that we have here
another condition is that this e i on
double derivative of w with respect to x
that is equal to zero
okay so now the boundary conditions
uh at x equal to zero
w is equal to 0
that implies if i substitute x equal to
0 here this just gives me
a this vanishes this also vanishes
and i am left with this
all right next at
x equal to l w equal to 0
that gives me a
cos k l plus t
sine k l plus c l
plus d equal to zero okay there is not
much
that i can do here except i mean one can
argue that
this d can be substituted by minus a but
right now that doesn't really do me any
good
okay so we'll come back to it next at x
equal to zero
okay uh now please note that uh
once we have this let's just find out
the the expression for
uh for d squared w d x
square and please note that i'll be
doing this at one shot uh
not okay so i'll skip a skip a step
what i'm going to get here is minus
a square a
cos kx and minus k square
b time kx
all right so
at x equal to zero um what i have to use
is e i d squared w
d x square is equal to 0
and that is going to give me if i just
substitute
x equal to 0 here i don't have to bother
about this e i
uh because the right hand side is 0
so this is just going to give me
minus k square a so this is
just giving me 1 cos k l z
cos k 0 is 1 and this is just going to
give me
0 the whole term is 0 because sine k is
0
okay so this is 0 which implies
that a is equal to 0.
now the moment we have a equal to 0
we can go back here and say
that d is equal to minus a is also equal
to 0.
okay next
at x equal to l i again have the
condition that e i
d square w d x square
is equal to zero
so what that gives me see
i have already found out that a is 0 and
d is 0 so here
you see what i'm getting from this thing
is that
minus a square a cos
l minus k square
b sine kl
but really i mean this a is 0 so we
don't have to worry
ultimately what we are obtaining from
here is this thing
that
b sine a is equal to zero
okay now uh
if you just go back here and see that
this a is zero
this d is 0 and we have just found out
that b sine k l is equal to 0 which
means
that t l
is equal to minus b sine kl
which implies that c is equal to 0
okay now if we come back to this
equation b
sine k l equal to 0 and
we think that this equation is going to
be solved
or is going to be satisfied if we take b
equal to 0
then what we are basically ending up
with if you just look at this expression
for w
is that a is 0 b 0 c 0 and d is 0 so w
is 0.
so this is not a very interesting
solution we say in mathematical terms
that this is a trivial solution so of
course if you have that kind of an
equation w
is equal to 0 is a solution but that's
not very interesting
especially not interesting because we
are looking
to find uh or investigate the
possibility of
buckling okay so we really need to find
a solution for w which would be non-zero
okay so what i mean to say is here that
if you look at this diagram
then the buckling would have
we would say that buckling is indeed
occurring
if there is a non-zero deflection in
this z
direction so it really does us no good
if we end up with a solution which says
that w is always equal to 0 that is
there is no deflection along the z
direction
that is not at all what we are looking
for uh if we are interested to study
buckling okay so the question arises
that okay that is a certain possibility
even though it is not interesting but
is there any possibility okay that is
the key question to ask
is there any possibility that even if
uh
we have this kind of a thing there there
may be another
alternative solution where w may not be
zero
does that solution exist okay so if that
solution
exists then the only possibility in our
hand
is to claim that b is not equal to zero
okay so the only possibility the only
chance we have left
for w not to be equal to 0 identically
is for b not to be equal to 0 but this
particular
entire combination b sine k l has to be
equal to 0 that we have found out
mathematically
so the situation is like this this
particular combination is equal to 0
b itself should not be 0 if we need have
to end up with
buckling that means sine k l has to be 0
okay so it is through that argument we
say
that sine kl equal to 0
for nontrivial solution
sometimes in textbooks it is written in
very short
or non-trivial solutions the sign k
equal to zero
but you should always try to connect
that kind of a mathematical statement
non-trivial solution with what you are
actually looking for mechanically
in our in the problem at hand we are in
the problem at hand
we are looking for possibilities of
buckling
the mechanical phenomenon and that will
be possible
only and only if this b is not equal to
0
and which leaves us with the only
possibility that sine k
must be equal to zero okay so
uh how is this possible when is
sine k l equal to zero so sine k will be
equal to zero
if kl takes on
values which are multiples of pi so
you understand that this n
must be from the set of integers
okay but you note that this uh
i mean we have taken our
uh our k square is positive so there is
no guarantee that
k has to be positive or negative but if
one way to think that k
also is positive then uh you have to
really mention that
n must be from the set of positive
integers so otherwise if you if you
allow for the fact that k may be
negative then there is no such
restriction on this
but it is important to note that this is
not the set of natural numbers it is the
set of
uh is a set of integers okay so
including 0
because you see that if you take kl
equal to 0
that also is a is a possibility okay so
though
that's just mathematical speak but uh
let's see just what happens okay so so
what is this k
okay so let me go to the next page and
continue the discussion
we have arrived at this k l is equal to
n pi
k if you remember
okay so k uh
this k square is equal to p by e i okay
so what we are going to do
[Music]
is to take the square of this
now k square is p by e
i i take the
l square to the other side
so that p is equal to
n square pi square
e i by
l square now this answer that we have
obtained
it is a very very important and
classical result
from mechanics of solids
what this is saying is that for buckling
to occur
the force p the compressive force p
when it takes this kinds of critical
values
you see this pi square is just a
constant the young's modulus
is a constant parameter for a given
uh physical setup the eye is
just dependent on the geometry of the
cross section
the l is also dependent on the geometry
of the rod
is just the length of the rod so it is
uh this crucial factor here is this n
okay so
if uh if we take n equal to 1
to various things then what is going to
happen
is that for values like pi square e i by
l square
then 4 pi square e i by l square
those specific values our theory is
predicting
that buckling should occur marketing
should occur means that
you are going to end up with non zero
solutions of
w okay so for these values of p
for these values of p
we are going to have
non-zero values of w
which means this is just a different way
of saying that non-zero values of w
exist means that buckling has occurred
so this this is very good now uh
we have to be a little bit careful here
uh in noting
that suppose we we actually consider our
beam cross section here
like this and let's say that this entire
height is age and this
this width is b
so uh we know that
uh if you are considering the
let me just
so this is our beam okay so if you are
considering
a uh the bending about an axis like this
okay which is parallel to this top edge
and this bottom edge
then the second moment of area
is 1 by 12
bhq however if you are considering
the the bending uh
or the of the second moment of area
about this axis
okay about this axis then i
is equal to 1 by 12
h bq now if you look at this formula
here
this i uh it will depend on which kind
of
of an axis you are taking this i about
okay now so depending on the values of b
and h
now please do not be
biased by this particular diagram this
is just a generic diagram
you could have b larger than h or h
larger than b
so depending on those specific values uh
you have to see which
i is smaller okay the one
the value that is smaller it is that
value which is going to
predict the buckling first okay because
that is a smaller
value so it is like this that you are
keeping on increasing the value of
p from zero uh when it first
hits the smallest value possible for
buckling
then immediately buckling will occur
that's what the theory tells us
okay so from these two values the one
which is smaller
that will uh induce the buckling first
okay of course yeah you have to take the
value of n equal to one also here
so let me see uh with this knowledge
if i can draw some kind of a response
diagram
so what i will do is uh
also what another another important
thing uh very classical
phrase that we often use is the critical
buckling criteria or the euler buckling
criteria
so what we say is that the euler
buckling load so in in honor of
the swiss mathematician euler
leonard euler so this is
this p e as
is given by this i square e
i
i square e i by l square okay so
this particular combination is referred
to as the
euler buckling load p e and you note
that
that is just the specific value obtained
uh when n
is equal to one okay so what we are
going to do is we are going to
take this ratio
e by e e which is nothing but
just n square and then we are going to
try to plot this out so in the x axis
we are going to have this p by
p e and in the y axis
sorry about that
we're going to take w okay now
uh you see although this is a
this is a very tempting thing to do to
plot w versus p by p
but you note that there is a little bit
of a problem here
you see the solution that we have
obtained that is only just telling us
about the critical values of p which
will induce the buckling
but you see it we have still not
obtained the specific value of
b okay so let me go back to the previous
slide
you see this b itself that is still
unknown we have only predicted the
possibilities of buckling occurring
but we still don't know the specific
answer
to our deflection because until and
unless we know the value of b
we do not know what w is okay find that
a cos
x c x d they all vanish but we are still
left with w is equal to b sine k x
okay now
you can take different values of x now
we know the value of
k because we know this
ratio p by e i but we don't know what b
is so we really don't know what the
amplitude of our deflection will be even
though we know that its nature should be
sinusoidal like this
now this is an important point to note
when we are trying to
draw our response diagram you see
this p by p is nothing but n square
okay so if you take
different values uh okay so
uh let's say uh
so what we are basically doing here is
that we are considering
and this n square values like 1 and this
is
a 4. sometimes what you can do is
instead of
plotting this n squared what you can do
is you can plot on this x axis
n in which case these points will
be spread out like this uh so one and
then four and then
at a larger distance nine and so on and
so forth anyway
so now we have these things but for w
all that you can do is to draw something
like this
with dot dot dot
again at four it's dot dot dot
at nine this is dot dot dot
so what this dot dot dot means is that
uh
we really don't know what the what the
what the amplitude of w
will be what will be the deflection of w
okay so uh maybe you can think of it
uh so some some of you may argue that
okay we know w as a distribution of x
so where exactly what value of w are we
looking at so maybe you can take
uh take the value at x equal to l by 2
okay so no problem x equal to l by 2.
so if you do that you will get you have
some idea that w
is going to be non-zero okay so it's
like this
so this plot really is like this that
you have
you're going you're starting from n
equal to zero
uh so it is it's like this until and
unless
you hit n equal to one
it just flat lines like that okay and
then you have these
things and then the moment what is what
this theory is predicting is that the
moment you make this
n slightly larger than one again this
theory is predicting
that uh the buckling will not occur
so if you if you somehow manage to to
hit a load
which is which or suppose you apply a
load which is
larger than this value of 1
okay if it is larger than pi square ei
by l square but smaller than
4 pi square e i by l square then this
theory is predicting that
is not going to buckle now this
particular thing
that it does not predict buckling or
values intermediate between two critical
two such critical values that is a
little bit of a problem
with this theory it is it is one of the
drawbacks of this theory
that uh even though it is
predicting buckling or a value pi square
e i by l square
but for a slightly larger value it is
predicting uh no buckling which
which seems a little bit weird okay and
it is it is it is
uh i mean a problem with this theory
uh but within the confines of this
theory very theoretically speaking
uh you will have the situation that when
you hit the value four
pi square e i by l square or the value
of four times the euler buckling load
again it will show a non-zero deflection
meaning that
some buckling has occurred and so on and
so forth you keep on going like that
so there is room for improvement in this
theory also
even though it has it has managed to
improve on
the previous theory that we were talking
about uh where
the the bending uh and the stretching
were completely decoupled
this is the theory which has made an
improvement on that
and it has enabled us to to
predict buckling or bend or or
some kind of compression induced bending
as an instability that is the good thing
about this theory but at the same time
this response diagram tells us that uh
there is an issue with this kind
of non-zero predictions or
or non-predictions of buckling between
uh between the critical values
okay so ideally what should have been
the plot is something like this that
you start from from a value less than
one
you you you obtain this thing
okay you obtain a non-zero value of this
w but if you keep on
increasing the value of p by p so if you
go beyond this
it will still remain non-zero okay the w
will still remain non-zero
and if you keep on going like it will
somehow go on like that
that would have been a proper theory
okay that would have been a proper
theoretical prediction
okay so uh we'll see how we can
try to improve this theory also but that
is
for later okay on that note i will
end this video thank you very much